we can finally go ahead and introduce
the basic elements of the Bayesian
inference framework there is an unknown
quantity which we treat as a random
variable and this is what's special and
why we call this the Bayesian inference
framework this is in contrast to other
frameworks in which the unknown quantity
theta is just treated as an unknown
constant but here we treat it as a
random variable and as such it has a
distribution this is the prior
distribution this is what we believe
about theta before we obtain any data
and then we obtain some data which are
some observation that observation is a
random variable but when the process
gets realized we observe an actual value
numerical value of this random variable
the observation process is modeled again
in terms of a probabilistic model we
specify the distribution of X but we
actually specify the conditional
distribution of X we say how X will
behave if theta happens to take on a
specific value these two pieces the
prior and the model of the observations
are the two components of the model that
we will be working with once we have
obtained a specific value for the
observations then we can use the Bayes
rule to calculate the conditional
distribution of theta either a
conditional pmf if theta is discrete or
a conditional PDF if theta is continuous
and this will be a complete solution in
some sense of the Bayesian inference
problem there is one philosophical issue
about this framework which is where does
this prior distribution come from how do
we choose it sometimes we can choose it
using a symmetry argument if there is a
number of possible choices for theta and
there's reason to believe that they're
all equally likely we have no
to believe that one is more likely than
the other then the symmetry
consideration gives us a uniform prior
we definitely take into account an
information we have about the range of
the parameter theta so we use that range
and we assign zero prior probability for
values of theta outside the range
sometimes we have some knowledge about
theta from previous studies of a certain
problem that tell us a little bit about
what theta might be and then when we
obtain new observations we refine those
results that were obtained from previous
studies by applying the Bayes rule and
in some cases finally the choice could
be arbitrary or subjective just
reflecting our beliefs about theta some
plausible judgment about the relative
likelihoods of different choices of
theta now as we just discussed the
complete solution or a complete answer
to a Bayesian inference problem is just
a specification of the posterior
distribution of theta given the
particular observation that we have
obtained pictorially if theta is
discrete a complete answer might be in
the form of such a diagram that tells us
that certain values of theta are
possible with certain probabilities or
if theta is continuous
a complete solution might be in the form
of a conditional PDF that again tells us
the conditional distribution of theta to
appreciate the idea here consider the
problem of guessing the number of
electoral votes that a candidate gets in
the presidential election the electoral
votes are a certain votes that the
candidate gets from each one of the
states in the United States and there's
a certain number that the candidate
needs to get in order to be elected
president
one possible prediction could be a
statement that I predict that candidate
a will win but actually a more complete
presentation of the results of a poll
could
be a diagram of this kind which is
essentially a PMF here a particular
pollster collected all the data and gave
the posterior probability distribution
for the different possible numbers of
electoral votes and this diagram is a
lot more informative than a simple
statement that we expect a certain
candidate to get more than the required
electoral votes so what is next as we
just discussed the complete solution is
in terms of a posterior distribution but
sometimes you may want to summarize this
posterior distribution in a single
number or a single estimate and this
could be a further stage of processing
of the results so let us talk about this
once you have in your hands the
posterior distribution of theta either
in a discrete or in a continuous setting
and if you are asked to provide a single
guess about what theta is how might you
proceed in the discrete case you could
argue as follows these values of theta
all have some chance of occurring this
value of theta is the one which is the
most likely so I'm going to report this
value as my best guess of what theta is
and using a similar philosophy you could
look at the continuous case and find the
value of theta that which the PDF is
largest and report that particular value
this particular way of estimating theta
is called the maximum a posteriori
probability rule we already have in our
hands a specific value of x and
therefore we have determined the
conditional distribution for theta what
we then do is to find the value of theta
that maximizes over all possible Thetas
the conditional PMF of this random
variable capital theta and similarly in
the continuous case it's the value of
theta that maximizes the conditional PDF
random variable theta this is one way of
coming up with an estimate one can think
of other ways for example I might want
to report instead the mean of the
conditional distribution which in this
diagram might be somewhere here and in
this picture it might be somewhere here
this way of estimating theta is the
conditional expectation estimator it
just reports the value of the
conditional expectation the mean of this
conditional distribution it is called
the least mean squares estimator because
it has a certain useful and important
property
it's the estimator that gives you the
smallest mean squared error we will
discuss this particular issue in much
more depth a little later now let me
make two comments about terminology what
we have produced here is an estimate I
gave you the conditional PDF or
conditional pmf and you tell me a number
this number the estimate is obtained by
starting with the data doing some
processing to the data and eventually
coming up with a numerical value now G
is the way that we process the data it's
a certain rule now if we know the value
of the data we know what the estimate is
going to be but if I do not tell you the
value of the data and you look at the
situation more abstractly then the only
thing you can tell me is that I will be
seeing a random variable capital X I
will do some processing to it and then I
will obtain a certain quantity because
capital X is random the quantity that I
will obtain will also be random it's a
random variable this random variable
capital theta hat we call it an
estimator sometimes we might also use
the term estimator to the function G
which is the way that we process the
data in any case it's important to keep
this distinction in mind
the estimator is the rule that we use to
process the data and it is equivalent to
a certain random variable an estimate is
the specific numerical value that we get
when the data take a specific numerical
value so if little X is the numerical
value of capital X in that case little
theta hard is the numerical value of the
estimator capital theta hat so at this
point we have a complete conceptual
framework we know abstractly speaking
what it takes to calculate conditional
distributions and we have two specific
estimators at hand all that's left for
us to do now is to consider various
examples in which we can discuss what it
takes to go through these various steps